a continuación intentemos encontrar
cuánto es 2400 dividido entre 30 esta
vez vamos a intentar hacer ejercicios
sobre divisiones con números que sean
múltiplos de 10 de 100 o de 1.000 así
que pausa el vídeo e intenta ver si
puedes encontrar tu la respuesta ok
es hora de pensarlo juntos y esta vez te
diré cómo en realidad el cerebro lo
resuelve por ahora lo vamos a resolver
en este pizarrón electrónico pero poco a
poco vas a ser capaz de resolver esto
mismo en tu cabeza así que veamos 2400
dividido entre 30 bueno eso lo podemos
poner como una fracción de esta manera
tengo este 2400 que voy a poner de color
rojo sobre 30 de color azul y la razón
por la cual le estoy escribiendo esto es
porque ahora podemos escribir tanto el
numerador como el denominador como el
producto de un cierto número y de 10 o
100 o mil por ejemplo 2400 es lo mismo
que 24 por 100
y observa si tengo estos dos ceros al
final puedes ver esto como 24 veces 100
y 30 bueno por lo tanto como tenemos un
solo cero esto es lo mismo que 3 por 10
3 10 es observa este 3 está en el lugar
de las decenas así que queda 3 por 10 y
ahora lo bueno de verlo así es que
podemos dividir de manera separada 24
entre 3 y el 100 entre 10 así que eso es
lo mismo que bueno voy a tener esto por
esto otro es decir no va a quedar 24
sobre 3
100 sobre 10 y bueno 24 entre 3 esto de
aquí es 8 ya lo debes saber porque 3 por
8 24 entonces 24 entre 38 y cuántos 100
entre 10 bueno 100 entre 10 es igual a
10 así que nuestro cociente va a ser
igual a 8 x 1080 porque es lo mismo y
hemos acabado observa si tomo mi 24 y lo
divido entre 3 obtengo este 8 y luego si
tengo estos dos ceros y le quitó uno de
ellos me quedo con sólo un 0 y justo
aquí está en el 80 y por qué crees que
esto del 0 funciona bueno porque lo
único que estamos haciendo es dividir 24
centenas entre tres decenas entonces una
centena dividida entre una decena me da
simplemente este cero de aquí y 24 entre
3 ya vimos que es igual a 8 por eso me
queda
bien ahora hagamos otro ejemplo
solamente para seguir con esta idea e
intentar resolverlo de la misma manera
ya sea en un papel o en tu cabeza ahora
imagina que queremos calcular cuánto es
3.500 dividido por 700 pausa e intenta
resolverlo bien como lo hicimos hace
rato esto es lo mismo que si lo vemos
como una fracción de 3500 sobre 700 y
3500 ya vimos hace rato que es lo mismo
que 35% sobre 700 que es igual a 7%
ahora sí entre 100 se cancelan esto me
queda simplemente 1 y solamente me voy a
quedar con 35 entre 7 bueno pues eso es
igual a 5 y observa podemos decir 35
entre 7 es igual a 5 y pensar con
cuántos ceros me voy a quedar es
exactamente lo mismo pero
com tengo dos ceros que están divididos
entre otros dos ceros y por lo tanto se
cancelan y la razón del por qué esto
sucede es porque estos dos ceros de aquí
representan las centenas 35 centenas y
estos otros dos ceros representan
también centenas siete centenas y
entonces centenas entre centenas se
cancelan eso es lo mismo que 1 y por lo
tanto simplemente me queda 5 bien vamos
a hacer uno más solo para que quede bien
claro el punto y para que aprecies que
no es ningún truco de magia solamente es
hacer sentido de lo que ya desarrollamos
así que vamos eeuu no lo quisimos se me
ocurre no sé dividir 42 millones 42
millones
esto entre 60.000 te parecen 60.000 a
que será igual a esto bien es momento de
pausar y de que lo intentes por tu
cuenta
bueno usando lo que ya sabemos podemos
decir que 42 entre 6 bien eso es lo
mismo que 7 y luego si aquí tengo 6
ceros porque estoy hablando de millones
y voy a dividirlo por 4 ceros es decir
estoy hablando de 10 miles entonces me
quedarían seis ceros menos cuatro ceros
lo cual es igual a dos ceros entonces mi
respuesta tendría dos ceros esto sería
igual a 700 y una vez más no estamos
haciendo magia la forma en la que lo
obtuvimos fue bueno es 42 por y bueno
aquí tengo un millón tengo seis ceros 42
por seis ceros
dividido entre 6 por 10.000 por 40 6 por
10 mil y después dividimos 42 entre 6 y
dijimos que sus iguales
y de ahí salió es de 7 y si dividimos el
numerador y el denominador por 10
observa perdemos aquí un 0 si después de
vido por otro 10 pierdo otro 0 y después
de vido por otro 10
pierdo otro 0 y si por último dividimos
otra vez por 10 perdemos otro 0 y al
final todo este 10.000 en el denominador
se vuelve un 1 o bueno espera espera
espera tal vez otra forma en la que
puedes pensarlo es decir voy a dividir
el numerador y el denominador por 10.000
déjame hacerlo voy a dividir ambos por
10.000 abajo me queda un 1 y arriba
pierdo 4 ceros y nos quedamos solamente
con 42 sobre 6 lo cual es 7 y dos ceros
porque observa ahora tenemos un 1 en el
denominador y entonces esto es igual a